today on the matt wall show top hhs
official rachel levine appears on tv yet
again this week to push castration and
sterilization on kids but instead of
being a high-ranking federal official
levine should be in prison we'll talk
about why also 47 republicans get on
board with the federal government
redefining marriage many people on the
right have changed their minds on the
marriage issue in recent years but why
what compelling argument convinced them
we'll try to figure that out and the
heroic squad led by aoc are arrested and
frog marched in front of cameras with
invisible handcuffs a harrowing scene
indeed plus cnn discovers something
known as summer and blames it on climate
change all of that and more today on the
matt welsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
the supreme court decision overturning
roe is a huge step in the right
direction and it's long overdue
obviously but there's still a long way
to go to rid our country of abortion and
give all unborn children the right to
life that they're guaranteed by the
constitution did you know that if you're
currently on a phone plan with one of
the major carriers you may be helping
these left-leaning companies
donate to pro-choice causes of
candidates or you may be paying for
their employees travel expenses to get
abortions don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe and switch to the pro-life
pro-family cell phone company instead
charity mobile sends five percent
of your monthly plan price to any
pro-life charity of your choice you
don't have to compromise on values or
services because charity mobile offers
the latest 5g phones no device or
service contracts great nationwide
coverage and exceptional live customer
service base right here in the us as
well the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes need your
continued support you can help by simply
switching your phone service over to
charity mobile today and you could do
that easily call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com and
mention offer code walsh
the biden regime is uh not competent in
very many areas except one it is very
good at embarrassing itself and by
extension the rest of the country this
is its core competency i would say uh
the dementia administration constantly
finds new and creative avenues of
mortification
um it is historians agree i think the
first white house in american history
with an actual sexual fetish for
humiliation actually this this white
house has many fetishes even more than
it did when clinton was in charge and
that was on full display and rather
grotesque display i would say over the
weekend when administration officials
attended a party at the home of a french
diplomat
two of the most prominent and publicized
officials
of the bible administration were there
and they took a photograph together and
that image has circulated rapidly online
in it as you can see
assistant health secretary
quote unquote rachel levine and
department of energy official sam
britton both males both in women's
clothes uh are there together smiling
for the camera britain who i've
introduced you to in the past is an lgbt
activist who identifies as gender fluid
and also sometimes as trans i guess i
think he's also a drag queen who goes by
the stage name sister radioactive and
belongs to a drag group called the
sisters of perpetual indulgence where
all of the drag queens dress
like demonic um sexualized nuns and
britain has been very public about his
sexuality of course which is uh how he
got the job in the bible administration
in the first place
and because of his thirst for public
notice
we know
though we don't want to know that along
with being a genderfluid drag queen
demon nun he's also a dog fetishist who
enjoys having sex with men dressed in
leather dog outfits he calls himself a
pup handler and teaches classes on kink
at universities
that is the career path that led
directly to a position in a presidential
administration
at one time it would have led directly
to an insane asylum
today it takes you straight to the white
house though the distinction between the
white house and the insane asylum is uh
granted increasingly hard to discern
but sam brinton
is merely a pervert and a weirdo uh
levine is something even worse
at least britain cannot use his position
as deputy assistant secretary of spent
fuel and waste disposition in the office
of nuclear energy for the department of
energy that's his whole title to
advocate for and push
dog fetishism
i mean he may yet
make me eat my words on that i'm sure
he's looking for a way perhaps he'll
find it i'm not sure what the
intersection is between
spent nuclear waste disposal and being a
dog fetishist but i'm sure there's
something there he'll find it
um levine on the other hand as one of
the highest ranking officials and
certainly the most visible uh at the hhs
can actually in a much more direct way
use his position to impose his lifestyle
on the public and especially on children
that indeed is what he's trying to do
like so many of his ilk his primary goal
in life is to justify himself and
rationalize his life choices by
recruiting others to behave as he does
so he made headlines again this week
while appearing on msnbc with a message
of empowerment quote unquote
for children listen
i want to ask you also
about transgender americans because
you're the first openly transgender
official confirmed by the united states
senate in a recent op-ed you urge people
to base medical decisions and public
statements on real data and compassion
rather than slander and you spoke to
trans youth in florida recently
tell us what you told them
well you know it trans youth are
vulnerable um and they suffer
significant harassment and bullying
sometimes in schools or in their
community they have more mental health
issues but there's nothing inherent with
being transgender or gender diverse
which would predispose youth to
depression or anxiety it is that
harassment and bullying
now they're suffering politically
motivated attacks through state uh
actions against these vulnerable
transgender youth this is not based upon
data this is these are these these
actions are politically motivated and so
we really want to to to base our
treatment and uh and to
affirm and to
uh support and empower these youth not
to limit their participation in
activities in sports and even a limit
their ability to get gender affirmation
treatment in their state
now it really sounded like he said um
we really want to debase our treatment
which is a freudian slip if i've ever
heard one and probably the first true
thing he's said in decades if
accidentally of course
uh his claim
that that the suicide rate among quote
gender diverse youth is
uh and he says that it's you know it's
entirely due to bullying there's nothing
inherent in these identities that would
cause suicidal thoughts that claim is
totally baseless of course and
contradicts the data at every turn the
so-called gender diverse
have sky-high rates of suicidality no
matter how affirmed they are by society
that's what the data actually says
and has said in study after study after
study but levine simply lies with
abandon
disseminating propaganda making wild and
dangerously false claims constantly and
doing so behind the magical force field
of his transgender identity
it is a force field that served him well
after all
even his critics rarely mention
that levine
earned his promotion into the federal
government
after a disastrous tenure as health
secretary of pennsylvania
like so many other health officials in
blue states he responded to covet by
making the crisis significantly worse
every chance that he could
instituting the same policy
in pennsylvania that cuomo put in place
in new york levine sent covet infected
people
into nursing homes which led directly to
many deaths countless deaths
we'll never know how many because during
his federal confirmation hearing it was
revealed that much of the information
and data related to his nursing home
policy had uh gone missing
oops it's all gone can't find it
in fact at the time of the confirmation
hearing the death and case numbers for
over 100 of pennsylvania's nursing homes
were missing from the record completely
but but we do know at least one resident
in an elder care facility in
pennsylvania who did not fall victim to
levine's murderous policy and that would
be his mother because levine moved his
mother out of the system
right as he was moving covet patients
into it
far for the course in pennsylvania
though after all the governor of
pennsylvania tom wolf shut down most
businesses in the state in 2020 while
allowing his own business that has his
name on it a cabinet supply company
called wolf home product to stay open
it was granted the status of a
life-sustaining
essential business because you know
everyone knows that our lives depend on
high quality cabinetry
now both wolfe and levine should be in
prison on charges of corruption
as well as for the mass murder of their
state's elderly population
instead wolfe is still governor
and levine is being rapidly promoted up
the federal ranks
they both possess obviously the the
democrat get out of jail free card they
have the letter d next to their names
which which goes a long way that's
enough to shield wolf from any
accountability for his policies
but levine can add the ultimate resume
enhancer
i mean 10 years ago he was a 54 year old
white dude named richard
no victim points no social credit
languishing all the way at the bottom of
the victim hierarchy but then he grew
out his hair and took the name rachel
and everything changed four years later
he got his first job in government
now he's in washington dc fighting to
drug and castrate children
it's not exactly what we would call a
classic success story but
it is a very modern one
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know as a parent i know that uh one
of the most important
and sacred responsibilities that i have
is to instill
values the right values
in my children and i we certainly as we
talk about all time on this show you
know you can't rely on anyone else to do
you certainly can't rely on the state
but what if i or my wife were not around
to raise my kids and still still those
values uh well i don't want the state
deciding who that responsibility goes to
that's why having a will is so important
it will it's not about you it's about
your loved ones it's about the really
hard decisions that need to be made if
something were to happen to you you need
to lay out all the answers to questions
like life support or pull the plug
buried or cremated uh do your parents
get the kids your in-laws or maybe
neither if they're all crazy but here's
the deal the judge doesn't who's
deciding these cases he's not going to
know who your best friend is or who you
trust to raise your kids a will is
something that could take as little as
five minutes to set up and if you don't
do it you're acting selfishly to be
honest with you so go to epicworld.com
use promo code walsh and i'll even save
you 10 at the same time you can have a
comprehensive will starting at 119
and if you don't have will you're gift
wrapping money to the state by letting
the state use its will to decide
everything for you and your family and
your kids you don't want that don't
trust the state to make any decision for
your family go to epicwheel.com use
promo code walsh and get it done today
all right
a few more days out here in our
undisclosed log cabin in the woods it's
been
good it's been refreshing it's been um
educational you know for everyone here
especially
for my uh producer sean who's sitting
five feet away from me
and has can do nothing as i throw him
under the bus here um you know he's more
of a more of a city slicker type so not
as accustomed to the rustic life so
yesterday we had all the kids together
and uh we were you know just hanging out
and
sean tried to roast a marshmallow
over a citronella candle and
of course we learned him we warned him
it would infuse citronella flavors into
the marshmallow and it did you know so
that's fine it's a learning curve okay
we all have learning curves in life and
there could be worse ones out here in
the woods i think we can we can say
all right
um
we're all learning we're we're all
learning some some difficult things uh
some difficult things about the
republican party if you didn't already
know this the daily wire has the report
the u.s house representatives on tuesday
voted to pass a bill
that would codify same-sex marriage
lawmakers passed the respect for
marriage act
that's that's what they're calling it
we're going to respect marriage by
destroying it um and it was passed 267
to 157 with 47 republicans joining
democrats including gop leader
congresswoman elise stefanik and
national republican con congressional
committee chair tom emmer they were on
board
cnn reports house majority leader steny
hoyer said quote it is critical to
ensure that federal law protects those
whose constitutional rights might be
threatened by republican-controlled
state legislatures lgbtq americans and
those in interracial marriages deserve
to have certainty that they will
continue to have their right to equal
marriage recognized no matter where they
live the bill now moves to the senate
where at least 10 republicans would need
to join democrats before reaching
president joe biden's desk and i see no
reason why they couldn't get 10
republicans or more
it would also
um
legalize interracial marriage even
though the supreme court protected
interracial marriage in a ruling back in
the 1960s so it would legalize something
that's already completely legal and
which no one in the country is trying to
make illegal so that's very important as
well
um c-span capitol hill producer craig
kaplan reports
by administration support for the bill
white house officials said no person
should face discrimination because of
who they are or whom they love and every
married couple in the u.s deserves the
security of knowing their marriage will
be defended and respected
now on this interracial marriage bit
because well what does that have to do
with so-called gay marriage um some this
is this is something that's uh a
connection that democrats have been
trying hard to make
representative jerry nadler uh did this
when he was speaking on the floor of the
house and he brought up interracial
marriage as well let's listen to what he
had to say
the substantive due process logic
by which the court overthrew
roe v wade
applies equally
to obergefell to loving
to lawrence in other words to the right
to contraception to the right to gay
marriage
um
to the right to interracial marriage for
that matter and justice thomas mentioned
all that specifically yes he said this
case doesn't involve that
we're not deciding that yet
which is what the portion of his
concurrence that
mr johnson read but read the rest of his
concurrence where he said specifically
that we should overrule or reconsider
obergefell
and
uh lawrence which is
consensual which is gay marriage which
is consensual
sodomy he didn't mention loving though
the for some reason which is interracial
marriage maybe the fact that he's
intermarried and so senator mcconnell uh
maybe that had something to do with it
but the same logic applies there
okay so so nadler even says that there's
that that uh
clarence thomas
his his um
his statements are being used as the
basis for this law that they're trying
to pass but he even says that clarence
thomas never mentioned anything about
interracial marriage of course he didn't
so no one is talking about interracial
marriage interracial marriage has
nothing to do with it because
interracial marriage and this is why
there is again nobody in the country
advocating for
making interracial marriage illegal and
the reason is that interracial marriage
does not
create any problems for or pose any
challenge to
the definition of marriage there's no
there's no definitional problem when it
comes to interracial marriage which is
why nobody's talking about it
no one's making an issue out of it
except for the democrats
now they want to lump these things
together because they they are the ones
who want to draw a correlation between
interracial marriage and same-sex unions
they're the ones doing that
nobody on the right is doing
of course many people on the right as we
just discussed have just thrown their
hands up on the marriage thing
altogether that's why 47 republicans are
now on board and what they're on board
with okay let's be clear about what
they're on board with here um they're
not on board with
giving the issue back to the states
quote-unquote they're not that's not
what we're talking about here or you
know the common libertarian refrain of
get the government out of marriage
that's not what they're doing
they want the federal government
to redefine marriage
from washington dc
and impose that definition on all of the
states and all of the people against
their will that's what republicans are
now getting behind
this is a position
that would have been too radically far
left for barack obama when he ran for
office the first time in 2008.
and this now is what republicans are
saying
one of those republicans is
representative nancy mace
she says this is what passes for
conservatism in 2022 okay this is this
is this was her tweet if gay couples
want to be as happily or miserably
married as straight couples more power
to them trust me i've tried it more than
once
so making a joke about her multiple
divorces and then say yeah yeah let's
get on board with this radical far left
legislation
that affects
you know one of the fundamental building
blocks of human civilization
by the way nancy nancy mace i mean it's
kind of here neither here nor there but
she's the uh
she's the politician who
claimed a couple of years ago
uh that
she had been her house had been targeted
by antifa
and antifa there had been all this uh
graffiti and stuff at her house and
it was always kind of strange because
you think like why would antifa worry
about nancy mace she's the most if
you're on the left she's the most
non-threatening she's on your side so
why would you care about her and it was
just it was strange it seemed like a
little bit of a potential jesse
smellette thing you know that
republicans don't do it very often
that's what it seemed like and then she
said that the police were looking into
it and we never heard anything about it
again you know these these antifa that
showed up and they only vandalized her
house nobody else
interesting
and now she's coming out in support of
the federal government redefining
marriage look here's the problem
with all this uh quote unquote marriage
equality stuff and this is again all
something that conservatives understood
actually everyone understood everyone in
the world understood
until barack obama and a bunch of other
people suddenly discovered otherwise
right around 2012 or so and they never
explained why
you know all of these people on the
right and left who have changed their
mind about something as fundamental and
basic as marriage never really explain
why
what is it that convinced you otherwise
you thought that marriage was our
particular thing right and then you
decided that it's not and so why would
what changed your mind
just like all the people that decided
that oh you know what i think actually
men can have babies why'd you decide
that what what what happened that made
you decide what did you discover what
can you tell me about i'm very
interested when it comes to men having
babies and
marriage being redefined i'm very
interested in hearing about your
road to damascus moment when you saw the
light can you tell me about it no one
ever does
can nancy mays tell me about it
she can
here's here's the problem as i see this
is how i've always seen it i haven't
changed my mind
because no one's convinced me to change
my mind i haven't heard any argument
that i would find at all compelling
i've been shouted at a lot i've been
labeled names i've been called a
homophobe
those aren't arguments though see i
don't find that persuasive for a lot of
people on the right they do find that
persuasive all you have to do is shout
at them especially call them a homophobe
you know there might be some labels that
conservatives are comfortable ignoring
but um but many of them are not you can
get them with homophobe you call them a
homophobe they oh no no no no i'm not
that
i don't find that convincing see i don't
care if you call me that or any other
label doesn't matter to me
so as it seems to me
if two things are equal
they are the same
we heard about the dem you know we just
heard that marriage is is is equal
marriage equality
are same-sex unions the same as
equal to
heterosexual unions
um is so-called gay marriage
equal to
what is now
deemed traditional marriage or biblical
marriage which i just call marriage but
are these two whatever labels you put on
them are these two categories the same
clearly not why aren't they the same
well because the union of a man and a
woman has in principle the potential to
create of itself a whole new life
the union of two people of the same
gender does not have that potential
period
okay so these are two
not just different things
radically drastically fundamentally
definitionally
different things
the potential
of the heterosexual union to create
people is
largely why marriage exists it's why
society has cherished and protected this
institution because it has been
understood that a union which might
create a person
has to be protected by society it needs
to be stable it needs to be permanent it
needs to be protected it needs to be a
faithful uh relationship it needs to be
monogamous
because marriage exists as the
foundation of the family unit and the
family unit exists as the foundation of
human society and so that's why you take
it you give it a different name and you
put it
you give it a status that no other kind
of coupling possesses because none of
them have that inherent power
if marriages are strong
families are strong and if families are
strong society is strong
you know we know that from history we
know that from our own experience in
this society one of the most crucial
functions of marriage
is to create the basis upon which
and the context within which
children are created and born and raised
this is why society has a or had a
vested interest in marriage and why the
state has a vested interest in it
because bad marriages or non-married
procreative unions hurt everyone they
create poverty they feed the prison
system they create
drug abuse and crime and suicide and
everything else
the union between two men
cannot of itself create anything
therefore the state has no real interest
in it society has no real interest in it
and and and you'll notice that
the people who
tore down
so-called traditional marriage
they never they never did offer a new
definition
of marriage or or and
explain what marriage's new purpose is
like we had the definition before you
might not have agreed with it
right you might not have agreed
with what the with what the the
definition of marriage was
up until 15 seconds ago but it had a
definition
and we could speak coherently about the
fundamental purpose of marriage
i just did it's easy to understand what
i'm saying
again even if you don't agree with it
you can still understand what i'm trying
to say because it's very clear
union between a man and woman has in
principle the potential to create human
life
serves as the foundation of the of the
nuclear family therefore serves the
foundation of of of society okay that's
it
then then and then the other side comes
along as they always do and they say
well no no marriage isn't that that's
not what it is
it's something else
and then we say well okay well what is
it then
what what is what's the new thing that
it is
uh you know it's just it's whatever
they never had a new definition and as i
said not they never had a new purpose
either
i can tell you what the purpose of
marriage was before
foundation the family foundation of
human society pretty big purpose pretty
important purpose what is it now
so the most we could ever most we've
ever been told is that well um
uh you know it's when two people love
each other
what does that mean and and why do you
need to be married to love each other
and if love is the one prerequisite here
then on what basis do you limit this
union to two people or
uh or to
adults or whatever
you know what basis do you do
now you're now you're drawing a bunch of
other arbitrary lines whereas before you
didn't need any arbitrary lines anyway
there were lines where they weren't
arbitrary
there was a sensible boundary before now
there's none
what are the new boundaries
and why are they there not somewhere
else
marriage went from a coherent thing with
a certain purpose and function in
society
to this vague and ambiguous thing
defined only by love which also they
cannot define nor can they explain why
love should necessitate marriage in the
first place
and in spite of all of these problems
so many people on the right were still
convinced
they came along and said we've got uh we
don't want the old definition of
marriage anymore
we don't know what the new definition is
and many people on the right said okay
sounds good to me
i'm convinced
by no argument
it's uh
pathetic
all right
this is something let's move from from
that pathetic display to something more
inspiring this is the i think the most
inspiring story of the week pro-abortion
protesters in dc out on the streets
again
uh they promised a summer of rage but
that kind of fizzled out instead they
have settled on more of a
a summer of um
mildly annoying people and so that's
what they've been doing and they were
doing that in dc they were out blocking
traffic
and sit in the street blocking traffic
and and the protesters were given
multiple warnings by police say you
gotta get out of the street we're gonna
have to arrest you and they stayed there
because they wanted to get arrested
because it's all publicity stunt
and um and so the police ended up
arresting a bunch of people including 17
house democrats who were there for the
pageant
um and were taking part in it none of
them were put in jail or anything like
that uh none of them were charged with
anything serious or anything at all but
they were arrested technically because
that's what they wanted that's why they
were there
that's why they came out to participate
in the stunt and that's why video went
viral of representative alexandrio casey
cortez
she of big booty fame being marched away
in handcuffs let's watch this if you
haven't seen this footage yet
you have to see it um so let's play it
now
[Music]
okay so you see her being marched away
there by the cops
and she's in she's in handcuffs but
actually the handcuffs are invisible
because okay and then she raises her
fists there so she forgot she forgot
that she was pretending to be in
handcuffs and she raised her fists and
said oh oops sorry
um but you know so they're invisible
handcuffs and they also allow for full
range of motion
that's possible
now some are looking at this footage and
they're saying the empress has no
handcuffs
but i look and say
wow
what an inspiration because listen even
if she isn't technically handcuffed and
we don't know that
because can you prove that she didn't
have invisible handcuffs can you prove
it do you have evidence that that
they have not invented invisible
handcuffs and put up you don't have that
evidence
but even if she wasn't okay
even if she was even if it is as it
seems that she was pretending to be
handcuffed
she is still handcuffed by the invisible
restraints of systemic racism and the
patriarchy and toxic masculinity okay
i think that's the message here
this was a this was a symbolic
gesture meant to communicate all of the
many ways that she is oppressed
by our society
and then you can also see it there's a
different video with ilhan omar where
you see her
getting
carted away as well
uh so you see you see alexandria cortez
and then you see ilhan omar
also with hands behind the back
yep there she is
she has not only invisible handcuffs but
an invisible cop also that's
an invisible cop is escorting her away
in invisible hand restraints
these people will stop at nothing to
keep the squad down they're pulling out
all the tricks invisibility cloaks and
everything
now the joke's on you if you if you do
think this is this is this was all a
stunt okay if you're more of the cynical
pessimistic type and you think this is
all stunt
um if you think that this was that it
didn't work well that's where the joke's
on you because
um they did this
to get headlines exactly like this
from abc says just in representatives
acacia cortez omar and other house
democrats arrested an abortion rights
protest at the supreme court and then we
see the photo of them from the front
hands behind the back no mention that
they're choosing to stand like that that
they're faking the handcuffs uh that no
mention of that
so they got the photo up they wanted
that's all that matters
most people will will never read far
enough into it to find out that you
faked it most people aren't on twitter
so they're not going to see that twitter
was making fun of it for a day and
having fun with it um so most people are
going to see that this is what most
people will see they'll see just that
image
representative queso cortez arrested at
abortion and they see her just standing
there with hands behind them behind the
back
she got what she wanted out of it
just as most people probably still don't
know uh that she was crying over an
empty parking lot down at the border at
the very beginning of her public career
it makes it easier to pull stunts like
this when you have
you know
the media as your
propaganda arm
all right this is from new york times it
says with few able and fewer willing u.s
military can't find recruits
it says these are tough times for
military recruiting almost across the
board the armed forces are experiencing
large shortfalls in enlistment this year
a deficit of thousands of entry-level
troops that is on pace to be worse than
any since just after the vietnam war it
threatens to throw a wrench into the
military's machinery leaving critical
jobs unfulfilled and some platoons with
too few too few people to function covet
19 is part of the problem lockdowns
during the pandemic have limited
recruiters ability to forge bonds face
to face with prospects and the
military's vaccine mandate has kept some
would-be troops away the current white
hot labor market with many more jobs
available than people to fill them is
also a factor
but longer term demographic trends are
also taking a cold toll less than
one-quarter of young american adults are
physically fit to enlist and have no
disqualifying criminal record a
proportion that has shrunk steadily in
recent years
and shifting attitudes toward military
service mean that now only about one in
ten
young people say they would even
consider it now this article
starts with a very real problem which is
that we can't find people to join the
military you can't recruit for your
military which is a problem to say the
least
doesn't even begin to scratch the
surface though of the root causes of the
problem
military recruitment is falling
dramatically why well yeah the fact that
people are fat and slow and diseased in
this culture is certainly one aspect of
this issue but there are other aspects
also
like for example um patriotism
is not being instilled in the younger
generations or in anybody else
at this point
in fact it's quite the opposite people
are being taught to hate the country
kids are being raised to believe that
america is systemically racist that it's
the worst country in the world that it's
oppressive and all these things
well
the kids that are raised to believe that
they're not going to sign up to defend a
country like this
there's no sense of um
honor or sacrifice or selflessness being
instilled
in kids that's these are not virtues
that anyone cares about anymore
certainly the institutions that have
been put in charge
of raising and forming and shaping the
next generation of americans they don't
care about these things
sacrifice selflessness
when's the last time you've even heard
anyone talk about those virtues
honor and sacrifice
honor especially
um and this what this all means is that
the actual
pool of applicants is extremely small
but then the problem's even worse than
that because what about those candidates
okay what about the physically fit tough
patriotic men who are willing to
sacrifice
what about virtuous physically fit
patriotic men those are the sorts of
people you need in the military despite
anything we're told and all the girl
power stuff the people that you need in
the military absolutely are physically
fit tough patriotic men that's what you
need in your military
if you don't
have those then you don't have a
military and you don't have a country
pretty soon
but what about them
well
those are exactly the sorts of people
that are being alienated
these men
many of them don't want to join the
military
and be subjected to anti-white
indoctrination and discrimination um
equity and diversity training and all
the rest of it
they don't want to go to some foreign
hellhole
and serve and die alongside
a platoon of non-binary transgender
queers you know like that's not what
they're signing up for
it's just a fact
that's
these men who we need in the military
that that's not how you recruit them
that's not how you
entice them to serve
we are alienating those men
and it's being done on purpose
by the way
okay what else do we have we have cnn
with this headline
more than 100 million in the us face
excessive warning or heat advisories
as a dangerous heat wave continues
more than 100 million
it says heat alerts cover more than 20
states today and wednesday as well
across the southern plains and parts of
the northeast and temperatures will soar
above the century mark for 60 million
people over the next week all while
similar heatwave is bringing all-time
record temperatures to western europe
the weather prediction center said
dangerous heat will continue to impact a
large portion of the u.s this week with
now more than 100 million people under
excessive heat warnings or heat advisory
excessive heat yeah so cnn has
discovered the sinister phenomenon known
as
summer
so it's july excessive heat i'm not sure
what that means excessive i mean
first of all isn't that sort of in the
in the um the eye of the beholder here
isn't that kind of a subjective for me
excessive heat is over like 70. i
consider that excessive
but it's just it's a strange way of
phrasing it when you're talking about
weather
excessive like walking out of your house
ah this this is okay come on come on
weather this is excessive
take it easy a little bit
and the way that they're
framing this
talking about the number of people who
are experiencing quote excessive heat
you know that's that's clever
i mean it's if you know it's it's a
clever trick that will fool you if
you're very stupid so i guess it's not a
very clever trick but it is a trick
because uh
of course the more people you have in
the world
then the more people who are going to
experience hot temperature so you could
say certainly
that
billions more people
this year will experience hot
temperatures
than experience hot temperatures 100
years ago or a thousand years ago
that's obviously correct because there
are a lot more people around to
experience temperatures in the first
place
but
heat in the summer all the same whether
there are seven billion people on earth
or one person on earth heat in the
summer is not shocking and uh
in fact it'd be much more alarming if
the summer came and went and no one ever
broke a sweat
on the same topic here thomas massey
had a wake-up call yesterday for the
climate alarmists i thought he raised a
good point here
we were talking yesterday about the um
the give and take here it's it's
the the climate alarm is the
environmentalists are
always proposing this supposed green
technology so-called green technologies
and then and then they propose them as
if they're utopian and there's no
downside and this is going to save the
the planet and um
and you know all upside no downside kind
of thing
but there are always there's always a
give and take there's always a downside
there are always side effects
and thomas massey talks about some of
those let's listen to this
the average uh household uses 17 of
their electricity for air conditioning
and
that would mean the average household
uses
1
870 kilowatt hours per year for air
conditioning if that average household
plugged in electric cars
do you know how much more electricity
they would use in comparison to the air
conditioning that air conditions their
whole house no but again i would
emphasize it well let me help you let me
help you with that first before we go on
because the numbers are important it
would take four times as much
electricity to charge the average
households cars as the average household
uses on air conditioning do you think
that could be so if we reach the goal by
2030 that biden has of a 50 adoption
instead of 100 adoption that means the
average household would use twice as
much electricity charging
one of their cars as they would use for
all of the air conditioning that they
use for the entire year
yeah it's a
pretty good point actually
yeah you switch over to electric cars
and this by the way was in a
conversation with uh pete butterjudge
who has said many times and he said
during this hearing as well that um the
high gas price and everything is
actually it's great because it's an
opportunity just for everyone to switch
over to electric cars because that's
something that's within the realm of
possibility for average americans
apparently you know the average
working-class american can just because
they're they can't pay for gas
and so a a reasonable solution for them
is to go out and buy very expensive to
go out and buy a tesla
that's that's pete budage too
you know working class family three kids
making fifty five thousand dollars a
year can't afford five dollars a gallon
for gasoline well you know what you
could do just go buy a tesla yeah no
probably that's what i did
why can't you do that
but even if that were feasible okay even
if it were possible
now you have
um
the
a a whole bunch of of households
millions of households using a lot more
electricity than they were in the past
four times as much
and where does the electricity come from
electricity is not
magical
it comes most of it
over 60 percent of the electricity in
this country is generated by the dreaded
fossil fuels coal natural gas petroleum
and so on
so
by switching over everyone over to
electric to electric cars you are still
depending on fossil fuels
and if everyone is using electrolytic
guitars you need much more electricity
then your generating capacity for
electricity needs to go up also by like
400 percent which means you need a lot
more of the fossil fuels
or if you're going to increase your
electric your electricity needs
by 400 percent or more
and not increase your generating
capacity that means that what do you
have then you have rationing
then you say to each household this is
how much electricity you get to use up
and uh once you're done for the month
you're done
now you have the rope basically rolling
blackouts nationwide
in perpetuity forever
and of course the
democrats
they would hear this and although
they're not going to say it out loud
what they would say among themselves is
yeah exactly
that's exactly what we're going for
energy rationing
is the ultimate goal from them for them
you want to talk about being able to
control and manipulate people
i mean you control their energy
consumption then you control them
because life modern society is powered
by energy
control that you control everything
that's the ultimate goal all right let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
uh first comment says matt if you had a
time machine would you rather go back in
time to see how it used to be or forward
to see how it will be love your work you
know honestly if i had a time machine i
would go i if it i would just use it to
drive to the supermarket you know if it
was like that kind of if it was a back
to the future type vehicle i would just
use i would i would stay right here in
in uh
modern times i wouldn't go anywhere with
it
and not because
everything is perfect in modern times
not at all we have a lot of problems
which i spend every single show talking
about
but um
i still don't have any great desire to
live a hundred years ago
nor do i have any great desire to just
like leap frog
all the way in to the abyss of our
dystopian future and live there so i
think i'd right just i'm just going to
stay here and kind of ride it out and go
where it takes me i think
um cool papa j magic says i admit i get
pretty annoyed when people say things
like man look at how crazy everybody is
on both sides no there's no comparison
between far left or far right i'm so
tired of this rational centrist act this
is not a game of stay in the middle this
is a battle of good and evil be on the
side of good because compromise with
evil is evil in itself couldn't have
said it better myself um
the problem on the right is not that
people are too radical or
too far right you know have taken their
what have taken the uh the conservative
principles too far
is that the issue that we have on the
right no i mean what do we just
what do we just talk about a few minutes
ago 47 republicans getting on board with
the federal government
the the wanting to give the power not
just to the federal government in
general which is bad enough they want to
give the power to
joe biden
to come up with a definition of marriage
and impose it on on they want to give
the power to the federal government
right
run by joe biden to impose a definition
a redefinition of marriage on entire
country so that's what's happening on on
the right that's what's happening among
conservatives so i would certainly agree
with you the problem is not radicalism
on the right far from it
the fish says uh
s is for shut the hell up you damned cry
babies we need that in the merch shop
for sure
i could see that we we workshop that a
little bit
you know yeah can we take s's for shut
the hell up you damn cry babies if you
could do it in like the sesame street
style i don't know that might be a
copyright issue we could talk about that
though i always appreciate
suggestions for the merch store and uh
many times this is like really a
this is an effort this is kind of a
crowdsource effort with the merch store
um
lying cat says oh and does the
definition for male have the same
nonsense definition as female now
wouldn't that end up in a circular
definition
yeah it does so we talked about
yesterday trans activist
succeeded finally and pushing for a
redefinition of female
in the dictionary and so now it says the
gender identity opposite of male what's
the definition of male well yeah the
definition of male now is the gender
identity identity opposite of female now
the interesting thing is that
actually
opposite of male
is an essential part
of the definition of female
it's good to include that if you want to
have a more
complete definition of female that
should be in there
because it denotes that there are only
two options which is important
and um it also shows that in some ways
each sex is defined by the fact that it
is not the other sex so it shows kind of
the complementary nature of the sexes
and it also shows that the sexes are in
fact binary
so that's an important part of the
definition it can't be the only part of
the definition though obviously it can't
be the only thing that defines it
because if it does then we have no idea
what this thing even is
and to see how that's the guess i mean
just imagine if i said um
if i you know was using the word
huggable and you said what's a hug of
blue and i said well it's the opposite
of a bugaboo and he said well what's a
bug of blue that's the opposite of a
huggable
i have no idea what these words mean
it's just nonsense now which is what
they've done with male and female
and jordan says does art even exist on
the right don't the constricting
principles of conservatism preclude any
real artistic expression who are the
biggest right-wing artists physical
musical theatrical cetera of the last
decade or the last century
well your point is partially valid um
you know it's it's hard to go back a
century for this question as the
delineation between right and left
according to modern standards anyway it
gets more complicated when you're
applying you know our modern ideas of
right versus left
a century ago becomes more difficult but
certainly
in current times
there's no doubt
that all of the arts are dominated by
the left
and and the artistic output
in our country has generally gotten
weaker over time partly for the reason i
described yesterday
for whatever reason great art
often seems to be born partly from pain
and frustration people you know figuring
out how to work both within boundaries
and then and break them but our artists
today are all fat and comfortable
they've achieved total cultural victory
they're now
living life as the victor and it doesn't
make for interesting art
but
your statement that that being on the
right precludes artistic expression is
obviously not true okay
um
i mean just think about the great
how many examples from history do you
really need i mean think about the great
renaissance artists right um
would they count
by by our definition today would they be
considered left-wing liberals
you know if you go back in time and talk
to michelangelo would you think he'd
qualify
as a leftist by our standards today
now there may not be
much artistic expression on the right
today we're trying to change some of
that here at daily wire making films and
so on but there isn't much of it like
that's a problem that we've identified
which is why we're doing what we're
doing but it doesn't necessarily have to
be this way
because what's really needed to create
great art is beauty and truth art is a
reflection of an expression of
of beauty and truth
which isn't to say that all art has to
be happy
it doesn't mean that art can't be sad
and difficult and painful and all that
but it must be beautiful
to really
count as art to be art that's what art
is
and in fact
this makes conservatives the most
naturally equipped to create great art
even if in this culture they don't
the left is hamstrung by what we
discussed by their how fat and
comfortable they are but also
even more fundamentally by the fact that
that on the left
they reject beauty they hate it they
worship ugliness
and because of that they can't create
great art
so the left can't create great art the
right right now is for the most part not
even trying and so what do you end up
with you just end up with no real art at
all you end up with
marvel movies and uh ugly you know
architecture and and um
people vomiting onto a canvas and
calling it a you know
a painting like that that's what you end
up with
well a couple of notes i want to i need
to tell you about uh one is that over at
the daily wire at the dailywire.com you
can go to the to the store section go to
shop or you can just go to dailywire.com
shop go to the matt wall store i'm
always telling you what's going on with
the store because we always have new
things we add to it
and uh many exciting new new additions
so here's the latest um we have our
finally our definition of a woman shirt
which is adult human female and
especially with you know we can't rely
on merriam-webster anymore we can't rely
on the dictionary anymore to define
these words and so that's why you have
to put it just emblazon it on a shirt
and wear it around
and preach this the the gospel of um
of the fact that words have meanings
everywhere you go so go to dailywire.com
shop go to the matt wall store and get
your definition of a woman
shirt today
and i also have to note because if i
don't um
i'll hear about it that this this idea
for the shirt came from my wife my wife
was the one who came up with this and
said we need to have this in the store
so this is this is her all the proceeds
go to her actually they don't they go to
the daily wire but still she gets the
credit also if you in case you haven't
heard already last month we launched
daily wire plus it's our ever expanding
multimedia universe and the reason the
daily wire app on your phone now looks a
little bit different is because of this
daily wire plus deliver plus is
everything you love about the wire plus
the new home of jordan peterson the new
home of prageru dw movies and coming
soon animated and live action content
for kids it's where you'll find fearless
documentaries like my brilliant gripping
and necessary film what is a woman i say
necessary because even amongst our
supposedly elite academic institutions
there's considerable confusion on this
issue evidenced by the university of
pennsylvania nominating former men's
swimmer and current trans swimmer leah
thomas for ncaa woman of the year in
fact he's
former and current men swimmer even if
they call him a woman now and while many
are quick to endorse leah for this
prestigious award in just his fourth
year of womanhood there are others who
are less than impressed by leah's
achievements including one of leah's own
teammates who i interviewed in my film
there's a reason what is a woman is
currently one of the most streamed and
talked about films of the summer and
now's your chance to see why what is
watch what is a woman by becoming a
daily wire plus member and you can get
35 off when you sign up right now
it's time to build the future you want
to see we need your help to do it become
a member at dailywireplus.com
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
although virtual reality has always been
featured prominently in fictional
fictional versions of our dystopian
future for a while it seemed like it
wasn't really going to catch on in the
real world sort of like how all the
sci-fi writers in the mid-20th century
universally agreed that we'd have flying
cars by the early 21st century and yet
here we are in the actual 21st century
and the technology exists technically um
and there are companies that are
actually trying to build these
contraptions flying cards
but most of us have come to realize that
that having everybody fly around in
their own personal aircraft would be a
disaster i mean most drivers can barely
manage to pilot their vehicles on the
ground it's horrifying to think about
what would happen if these drivers had
access to the sky
i guess those who made these predictions
by the future also assumed that the
average driver would have mastered the
fundamentals of using a steering wheel
by now but that has not been the case
and so flying cars have not taken off
figuratively or literally and probably
never will and if they do take off
most of them will certainly crash and
burn about 45 seconds later
i had always hoped
that virtual reality would suffer the
same failure to launch
and i felt heartened in recent months as
mark zuckerberg unveiled his metaverse
which is his virtual reality vision and
um i was encouraged to see how boring
and dull it is as we've talked about on
the show zuckerberg's great vision is to
create an immersive internet experience
where people can enter inside it like
the matrix crossing through a portal
into a limitless
3d virtual reality world
where they can have meetings and
conference calls
zuckerberg's cyber universe is
considerably more boring than the
regular universe and this is what
happens when you put like spock in
charge of designing our vr utopia
but i've probably taken too much solace
in this the fact is that
there are other vr platforms aside from
the hellish corporate seminar universe
that zuckerberg is creating and vr is
like it or not catching on there are
currently about 50 million vr users in
america today the whole industry is
worth about 8 billion projected to be to
grow to nearly 30 billion in the next
five years or so
more importantly
the most powerful corporations in the
world companies that have literally
made a science out of understanding and
predicting and manipulating our behavior
they are investing more and more into vr
technologies
we already know about what zuckerberg
and facebook are up to apple has its own
designs so does microsoft and google
these companies want a future where we
are all wearing their devices on our
heads blocking out the entire physical
world from our view and living our lives
entirely within the alternate reality
that they create for us
it's not hard why it's not hard to see
why they find that so appealing
the entertainment industry is buying in
now too hbo max will soon release what
is what is being called a groundbreaking
documentary and it's groundbreaking
because
it is the first film made entirely in
virtual reality the website vr scout has
more it says shot during the height of
the cove 19 pandemic we met in virtual
reality as an upcoming documentary from
the director hunting that follows the
lives of five specific individuals using
vr chat and modern vr technology to
connect with others in a variety of
unique ways the 90-minute film was shot
entirely in vr at no point do we learn
the real world identities of its
subjects says the director the film
presents an immersive journey through
the world and different vr chat
communities each individual that you
meet shares really unique experiences on
vr and each engages with their community
in different ways for them vr means very
different things through their eyes the
film presents a very broad portrait on
how social vr can affect our emotional
and social relationships with each other
but also within ourselves
the trailer was released a few days ago
here's a peek at that
making friends here is sometimes what
saves people's lives
or what gets him up out of bed in the
morning
i am a teacher for helping hands a sign
language community here in vr chat hand
rested under elbow and we're gonna go
like this christmas
slow
quick quick slow if i had confidence
that i could teach dance as a living in
vr i totally would do exactly that with
a long distance relationship having vr
is a game changer we are 5 000 miles
apart but we're gonna try our best to
make it work
this year has been really hard the thing
that has kept me sane has been vr and
the vr community
i would not have weathered this without
you guys
[Music]
you can be who you've always wanted to
be
and you can in a way start over
we can come together and support each
other this community means a lot to me
and i really want them to know that
they're loved
in a year since i've seen kevin's irl
body
well isn't that beautiful people
connecting forming communities falling
in love
you can start over says one of the vr
um fans
you can be reborn
you can be whoever you want to be
provided that you want to be a weird
creepy anime avatar like if you want to
be that you can be that
this all sounds like a utopia with no
downside at all right so what's the
problem
well there are many problems it turns
out we've talked about some of them
before but let's review first of all the
documentary is filmed in the platform on
the platform vr chat but based on the
trailer it seems to rather seems to give
a rather glossy and carefully curated
view
of this vr chat platform
an article on the site engadget gives
the other side of the vr chat story
headline is
investigation of vrchat finds rampant
child grooming and other safety issues
they report quote one of the more
popular vr apps you can download through
steam and meta's oculus quest store has
a child safety problem vrchat styles as
the future of social virtual reality our
our vision for vr chat is to enable
everybody to create and share their own
social virtual worlds the games
developer says on its steam store page
with some understanding of unity players
can create their own social spaces and
avatars that means you can see a lot of
creativity on display in vr chat but
there's also a dark side to it as the
bbc found out posing as a 13 year old
girl bbc researcher jess sherwood said
she entered a virtual strip club where
she saw adult men chase a child while
telling them to remove their clothes in
many of the rooms sherwood visited she
frequently saw condoms and sex toys on
display and on one occasion even saw a
group of adult men and minors simulating
group sex she also saw instances of
grooming
well
it turns out that virtual reality is
even in its fetal stages infested by
perverts and pedophiles of course no
surprise
just look at what happened in our
real-life cities when we told everyone
to wear a mask
anonymity removes accountability and
removes shame which invites chaos
now put people in virtual world with
full anonymity an entirely new and fake
identity and also empower them with the
false notion that nothing is real in
cyberspace
as if human being as if the human beings
they're interacting with don't even
count as human beings
tell them that the normal rules of
morality and decency no longer apply and
suddenly it becomes like the purge every
day all day
except more sexual and with a lot more
child molesters
this is just one of the problems with
virtual reality the fact that the
internet is a is a hellish place
where people act monstrous towards each
other because they feel empowered to do
so
but that's not the full indictment
i mean in theory putting all the sex
predators aside for a moment which is
very hard to do
when you're talking about anything
related to the internet
um but putting that aside
there's nothing wrong with vr and small
doses as a fun gimmicky little diversion
but we know that people in our culture
don't engage in escapism entertainment
in small doses they turn it into a
lifestyle that's why even in the in the
trailer for the documentary we begin
with some users discussing practical
applications for the technology teaching
sign language for instance seems like a
okay yeah that's that's one area where
it seems like that would be um that
would make sense
but very quickly we start hearing how vr
is really an opportunity to form loving
bonds and find community and reinvent
yourself and restart your life and find
meaning and everything else
so the pipeline from escapis escapism
entertainment to lifestyle choice is
short and the transition from one to the
other happens at near lightning speed
we are a culture obsessed with escaping
vr offers the most complete form of
escape short of suicide
the user can block the entire physical
world from view enter into the internet
recreate themselves according to their
own vision or rather according to the
vision of apple or microsoft or facebook
which they will be tricked into thinking
is their own vision this grants almost
unlimited power to these tech giants
allowing them to control manipulate
track and monetize your every movement
literally
i mean think about for a second or what
they do on the social media platforms um
the way they're able to predict your
behavior just based on just based on
what you search for and you know like
the kinds of posts you click on and
everything
that's why people often think when they
see ads pop up and uh and they they
think oh the phone's listening to me no
it's not listening to you it's even
worse than that they've built technology
that can just predict what you are going
to want to they can predict the kind of
ad
like you were just talking about
something you want to buy you've never
searched for it before and then the ad
pops up
no the phone didn't hear you say that it
just predicted based on your behavior
that you would want a product like that
and then you did
which is a lot scarier
now give them that kind of predictive
capability
when they can also track your movements
everything
what happens then
but worse it further severs you from
your physical existence and your actual
true physical self now it sounds like
new like sort of new age claptrap to say
that people need to be reconnected with
themselves you know find themselves and
it is new age claptrap but in this case
the new age claptrap is inadvertently
true
as human beings in modern culture
you know we find various and ever more
elaborate ways of hiding from ourselves
shrinking away from our actual lives and
bodies
and as that happens the job of rescuing
society from collapse and despair
revolves more and more around
encouraging people to live authentically
be yourself not in the bumper stick or
slogan kind of way but in a deeper more
urgent sense inhabit your own life be
yourself yourself
live in and interact with and see the
world the physical world accept it and
understand it and appreciate it for what
it is
these days we're always
out looking for any kind of reality but
our actual reality
and that's why our actual reality never
improves
and that's why virtual reality is once
again today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode an
historic shift is taking place among
voters about which party they trust more
with education
texans are asked to conserve energy and
water amid energy grid and drought
struggles and la county takes steps to
remove its tough on crime sheriff
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
[Music]